[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
is the Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [__] eating
[__] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
oh boy
the Republican Nazis are out today
questioning attorney Janet
attorney general Merrick Garland about
Hunter Biden
you know what's really funny that I
noticed about listening to these
chuckleheads just completely [__]
lying in front of the American people
when they're questioning the Attorney
General of the United States you know
what I noticed more than anything that I
noticed they have absolutely taken the
word laptop
out of their vocabulary
we ruined that for them oh my God wildly
ruined the idea that the laptop had all
the evidence on it remember this
remember remember when the laptop was
the most important thing ever in the
history of ever ever don't you remember
this this was gonna be the thing that
exonerated Trump and it made Biden
resign and he was gonna
he was going to resign and Trump was
going to enter the White House that
laptop remember remember everything
about that lamp oh my God it was about
everything laptop laptop laptop laptop
do you remember then this was only a few
months ago it has not been that long ago
that the the entirety of the Republican
party's hopes and dreams was penned
on a computer than Hunter Biden used to
own and really it was they copied it and
added [__] to it they still Rudy
Giuliani stole it
they stole it from Hunter Biden a copy
of his hard drive
let Parnes has said almost as much maybe
not in so many words but Rudy Giuliani
at the direction of trump stole Hunter
Biden's lamb tub this morning they got
barisma brain and Hunter Hunter hog
syndrome
in the hearing they can't stop focusing
on Hunter Biden running for president of
the United States it's insane
honestly I you know after all this after
all the [__] they'd said this morning
I'm considering not voting for Hunter
Biden for sure
I actually I don't think I'll be voting
for Hunter Biden in 2024
or ever really
oh my God what a bunch of [__]
boneheads
hilarious that they're trying to
convince their sheep
that that the U.S attorney Weiss who is
appointed by Trump in Delaware to
investigate Hunter Biden he was
appointed to investigate Hunter Biden
and because those investigations were
open under Trump you [__] boneheads
Biden and Merrick Garland backed away
and said keep going whatever you come up
with is what you come up with
when the deal fell apart in open court I
don't know if you guys remember this
there's no cameras in federal court I
know everyone wants them but there's no
cameras so we have to rely on like I
don't know reports and transcripts but
what happened in federal court is that
the prosecutor
Weiss did not hold to the agreement that
they made with Hunter Biden and his
counsel and Hunter Biden said no no no
[__] that's not the deal you
made that's why that deal fell apart it
wasn't the the judge or or Weiss was
going easy on Hunter Biden
and it appears now the reason why Weiss
asked for special counsel privilege is
so that he can charge him in other
districts
on these [__] [__] gun charges
which honestly any two a bro out there
that looks at the charges that Hunter
Biden was charged with with their
interpretation of the Second Amendment
which is boneheaded at best
would be yelling and screaming to drop
those charges but they're not because
it's a political Witch Hunt that's what
an actual political Witch Hunt looks
like folks that's what it actually looks
like
and I don't blame Hunter Biden pursuing
everyone in sight and going and
challenging the Merit of the charges
against him based on their
interpretation of the Second Amendment
I bet he wins that [__] I bet he wins
that case
I don't know if you know this
Hunter Biden's got a lot of issues in
his life
he's had a lot of tragedy in his life
[__] a guy up I mean anyone who's lived
through that type of tragedy knows
that it's not easy
when you have to go through those sorts
of things especially at a young age like
Hunter Biden was
I don't know if you [__] scumbags
know this who hate Hunter because he's
got a bigger dick than you but the
reason why the guy is a little bit
[__] up in his mind is because he was
in a car accident his mother and his
sister were killed in
you [__] idiots
it'll [__] with a person a little bit
especially if that trauma stays with
them
you [__] idiots
but it doesn't it doesn't discount
Hunter Biden's intelligence
and his ability to be an attorney and
his bill ability to make business deals
around the world which has made him a
shitload of money more money than Don Jr
and Eric Trump could do without
wandering yeah that's right without
wandering trumps would be nothing they
spent their Grandpa's fortune and their
dads and Trump's dad's Fortune already
10 times because they're [__]
boneheads
I know continue to be [__] boneheads
it's not gonna stop I mean [__] Donald
Trump Jr's Twitter account was hacked
that's a good day on Twitter
when Don Junior's Twitter account is at
but I digress let's get back to the
house Republican Nazis
questioning mayor Garland now there's
one instance and you're gonna love this
clip oh my God you're gonna love this
clip how this clip has not gone viral
yet I have no idea
represent Democratic Representative
Steve Cohen of Tennessee absolutely
stuffs Matt gatz into a [__] Locker
wants him up and dumps him in the trash
Oh my God
all the while absolutely
down downgrading Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan
from chairman
of the committee to [__] of the
committee all in one Fell Swoop
it is fantastic right before I came on
the air I was listening to Eric swalwell
I think I'm a behind a little bit on the
hearing is getting ready for the show I
had to pause it a couple times so I'm a
little behind but Eric swalwell started
to also bring out the flamethrower
to absolutely burn these house
Republican Nazis down to the ground
that's what this is folks
this is this is theater in propaganda
it is more house Republican lies it is
more the House Republicans focused on
what is already federal charges against
Hunter Biden like them or not
and David Weiss it's wise not being able
to find
any
any evidence of bribes of foreign money
because you damn well better bet if
David Weiss asks for special counsel
privilege to go to other states to
charge Hunter Biden with these gun
charges because he's mad
that they backed out on the deal because
David Weiss didn't hold to his end
which he's a republican so it's not
surprising that he did that um and he
was appointed by Trump to go after
Hunter Biden
but the point is this
is that
if
these Republicans decide that they're
going to do this before they govern the
American people will judge them and the
American people will hold them
accountable
we have an election coming up every
single one of these boneheads
are going to be up for election every
last one of them now what we have to do
is the pro-democracy Coalition is to
form a national narrative and messaging
and get people at the local level to run
against these boneheads
and Destroy them in the 2024 election
they're going to shut down the
government oh God they're projecting it
like crazy you have some Republicans out
there who are trying who are trying to
seem as if they're reasonable by calling
the other Republicans clowns and and
stupidity not they're not conservatives
they're stupid that's literally I'm
going to show you a clip it's literally
what Republicans are saying about
Republicans
there's a Civil War in this country and
there is and it's inside the Republican
party and the Nazis are winning
they're winning the Civil War inside the
Republican party because they're going
to shut down the government
again I told you yesterday to solve
[__] theater anyways
the theater of of some of these
Republicans who are in Biden districts
who want to win who don't want
impeachment hell they want to shut down
the government so they don't have to
continue to pretend to impeach the
president of the United States he was
one of the most effective presidents of
modern history
and then having to go to explain to
their constituents who voted for Biden
and who will probably continue to vote
for Biden why they should remain a
congress person it's going to be really
awkward
so it's all theater
all of it every last bit of it
no governance whatsoever none
not a single shred of covenants that is
coming from the Republican party and it
is because they do not know how
[__] Jim Jordan doesn't even know how to
run a hearing
doesn't even know how the rules work
doesn't know that he has time doesn't
know about how time works doesn't know
how about questioning after time works
he has no clue
I don't know if there will be clips of
Jim Jordan not knowing how to [__]
run a Committee hearing
but they sure certainly exist this
morning
because he has not a goddamn clue Daniel
Goldman has to keep telling him with
points of order how to run the [__]
committee
it's Insanity really honestly I cannot
believe that we are at a point in our
timeline that this type of bone-headedry
exists
and the only reason why is because it is
more about their political influential
social media Fox News Trader TV News
Network clout
than anything else
that's it they're trying to appease the
the orange mango Mussolini one
an audience of one and
they're trying to get their highlights
so they can get more more followers on
that social
I'm going to show you evidence of that
in a new ad put out against Ted Cruz
where he can't stop saying the word
podcast now I'm a little biased to
podcasts as you can tell but I'm not a
[__] member of the United States
Senate
I got plenty of time outside this show
to develop this show
I don't have to answer to a constituency
like Ted Cruz should have to answer to
he's not working for the State of Texas
he's working for his show
and he's using his seat in the United
States Senate to promote his show
and I'm not opposed to Ted Cruz having a
goddamn podcast if you want to know the
honest truth I'm not opposed to that who
would be opposed Ted Cruz having a
podcast where he says stupid [__] that
we can use against Republicans that
sounds pretty good to me
I mean Ted Cruz can't say anything other
than a culture War culture War culture
War yeah good luck with that
that's a fantastic narrative they're
their buddy
alls I'm concerned about is that he
should make his podcast his [__] day
job and leave the rest of us the [__]
alone leave us the [__] alone drop your
[__] senate seat drop out of the race
go do your [__] show and leave us
alone you piece of trash
I actually believe that it should we We
if we if we get to a place in this
country where we can
do some real governing
and have some normal states of being in
this country for a certain period of
time Jesus Christ maybe two years maybe
four years
God could give us six maybe the god that
everyone thinks exists
but Ted Cruz continues to promote his
podcast using his United States Senate
seat
speaking of shows and Showman
and phony culture wars Charlie Kurt
knows two at University I forget which
one
doesn't matter which one really honestly
he goes to a university and of course
he's being protested so he stages a
video so that he can post it online to
show you how how abused he is as a white
man what made her so oppressed look how
oppressed I am oh all these women hate
me because I want to take away their
rights
I mean so oppressed because I want to
oppress people get the [__] out of here
man are you kidding me keep going
Charlie do not take the shovel out of
these [__] hands as they're
digging their political grave
this idea this idea that they're gonna
rile up women by trying to take away
their [__] rights
I don't I don't know if they noticed
what happened in 2022 and what's
happened in some of the special
elections inside these states to secure
abortion rights or to keep [__] white
wrinkly old ball sacks men
that are legislators in that state their
hands off their [__] Health Care
I don't know if they've been paying
attention to that but keep keep going
Donald Trump says he's the reason why
why Roe v Wade is killed in this country
good
good own it [__] own that [__] that you
don't want women in the military you
don't want women to have health care you
don't want women to vote you don't want
women to have jobs you don't want any of
that [__] they do not want women as
anything but [__] property
doubt me [__] doubt me just go look
at their rhetoric go look at this go
look what Tommy tuberville is doing
do you think Tommy tuberville at this
point his entire [__] his entire
[__] narrative
around
government and and Military appointments
so that our national security can be can
can be at a level that it needs to be so
we can be ready
do you think that's about abortion get
the [__] out of here
are you kidding me you think Tommy
tuberville gives a [__] about abortion
he doesn't give two [__] about abortion
who God knows how many that
[__] paid for that's right I
said it who knows maybe he's paid for
him maybe that's why he thinks he knows
so much about him
the reason why they continue this stupid
ass narrative about abortion in the
military and holding up promotions is
because they are going to say they are
going trust me they're going to say at
some point well you know we solve all
this we just don't want women in the
military
that's what they're going to say and
that's where they're going that's where
[__] doubt me yeah
Ron DeSantis is talking about executing
people at the [__] border with no due
process of law
and I said years ago
that that's what where it was gonna go
that's where the hell they were going
with this narrative ah well we can't let
people across the board we can't let
illegals and all illegals taking our
jobs that we don't want that we can't do
migrants coming here and participating
in the economy is the reason why the
reason why women have abortions I don't
know what the [__] they think
or what excuses they give or what
cognitive dissonance they participate in
each individual bonehead has its own
individual bone-headedry
but that's the beauty of America isn't
it
that we can just pick up lies and throw
them around
and anyone but believe anything
[__] some people believe polls that are
out even even on the mainstream media
they believe these polls
are you kidding me you believe polls
anymore any poll anywhere get the hell
out of here with this [__] I'm gonna
show you evidence this morning that the
ballot the ballot is the only poll that
you need to believe period
that's the only poll that you need to
believe is the ballot that's it
that's the only poll that matters
anyways who gives a [__] what the media
says
about what's true and what's not oh look
at this look at this pole over here
George oh this pull this poll really
helps our narrative it really helps us
make money by uh by convincing our
audience that Trump is just as popular
as Joe Biden
[__] out of here with this nonsense
and to believe to believe that the
American people want the House GOP Nazis
to be representing them by continuing to
talk about Hunter Biden after he's been
indicted
he's being federally indicted
the guy could go to prison what the [__]
are you yelling and screaming about
still
well Weiss didn't do a good enough job
because he he really didn't believe the
lies that Fox News has been telling me
David Weiss can't prosecute lies in an
open court dummy
that's not how it works when you go to a
grand jury to get an indictment you have
to have some some sort of evidence
some
just because the existence of Hunter
Biden's business deals exist doesn't
mean it's evidence you [__] idiots
but they'll continue they're going to
continue this and continue and continue
and continue this and they're gonna
they're gonna be feckless
they're going to be Reckless
but they will be jobless if we have
anything to do with it
and that is the main key here
because that's really that's really the
thing we need to focus on
[__] [__] if Trump goes to try or not
[__] if he's gonna get more charges or
where [__] if he's got a gag order or
any of that [__] [__] that [__] one
Focus
and one Focus only democracy over
autocracy period
democracy over autocracy stay [__]
pissed get your battle right down to the
ballot is what you need to do
you need to have strategic outrage and
engage in your democracy that is what
that is what is going to get rid and rid
us of the GOP criminal Nazis
they are definitely that
I'm not gonna back away from calling
them Nazis because they are and if they
don't like it that's their [__]
problem and if you're mad that I'm
calling Republicans Nazis because you're
Republican I'm talking to you that's
right I'm talking to you so get your
[__] head straight
pluck your head out of your ass and
realize that you've been duped
that you're thinking is backwards
you're not going to survive as a
political party really frankly you
already did
well that's just the way it goes but
we're not dead and we're not going
anywhere we're going to be right here
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Facebook and twitch that's
right you can find all things the Tony
Michaels at the tonymichaels.com
do me a favor go subscribe to the Tony
michaels.com you can hit the Subscribe
button right up here at the top
I'll alert you to any changes like this
morning I sent you an alert to all those
subscribed
about the show and the link to the show
if you want to buy me a shot if you want
to get in on the Super Chat on the venmo
Super Chat that link is right here you
can send me a message I will bring it up
on the screen and thank you to everyone
that has joined the patreon for the
Monday and Friday Early Morning Show and
also all that have upgraded to the 20
tier for that show it's going swimmingly
and I also want to thank you for
everyone who signed up as a
consideration to be a moderator we are
going through those right now so just be
patient with us as we consider adding
more moderators to different platforms
we'll get to every single one of you
that have signed up if you want to sign
up to be a moderator go fill out the
form the link is right here the mod sign
up just click there and you'll be on the
list to consider I also want to ask you
if you have linked your Amazon Prime
account to your Twitch account I haven't
said this enough lately if you have
linked your Amazon Prime account to your
Twitch account please go please go
re-subscribe now go to twitch.tv Tony
Michaels and resubscribe you got to do
that every single month I know it's kind
of a pain in the ass but free money
isn't always free it takes a little bit
of work you know what I mean and you can
do that all the directions are here at
link Amazon and twitch you can click
there also I want to thank every single
one of you who went and subscribed to
the library of democracy's YouTube
channel yesterday let me check and see
where we're at with that they're almost
to 900 so we're so close yeah we're 868
right now to our goal for the library of
democracy and the quickest way to get
there is to go to the Tony michaels.com
click the library of democracy right
here you can go sub to it but you know
what I'll do I'll put it in the chat
right now you're not going to want to
miss out on the library of democracy
it's going to show you great content
great content on how to engage in your
democracy very quick ways easy ways ways
that you wouldn't think of two two
engage in your democracy and so all
that's there at the Tony michaels.com
Please Subscribe there at the attorney
michaels.com that's how we that's how we
get support here and this microphone
could not stay on without you that is
right this microphone would not be on it
would not be live or not be hot without
you whether it's monetary support that
you give or engagement whether you come
here and listen every single day whether
you download the audio episodes that's a
great way to engage that's a great way
to support the show is download the
episodes on audio every single day
but engaging chatting
sharing your stories
messaging sharing the links
that is what is important in this
democracy and it is important that we
stay in that mode of strategic outrage
it is going to take everything we got
all of it
not not only not only to win at the top
of the ticket
because that's that's very important to
win at the top of the ticket but it's
also important
to win those down ballot races not just
in the house and the Senate because
those down ballot races are super
important
but also to win at the ballot in these
states on the state level governors
Representatives state senators city
council School Board Mayors whoever it
may be wherever it may be we need people
who believe fundamentally in our
democracy ever we need
and if we if we do not have people all
over the country who believe in
democracy in those seats of
representation no matter where they are
rather again rather they're on the
school board or the state senate
or you're they're your Governor attorney
general wherever they may be
those seats of power those
Representatives must believe in our
democracy and the one issue we have
right now in this country is there is
only one party only one that is
interested
in democracy
and engaging in our democracy the other
one is hell-bent and focused this
morning even in the House GOP Nazi
conference to use democracy to destroy
our constitutional republic
because it's not it's not that they're
offended I'm going to show you
um a band of Anne Frank's diary in Texas
oh my God this is
such a perfect story to describe the
Republican Party
it's not that they're offended by this
they want to erase history so they can
repeat it
folks they want a 1930 style solution
in this country to democracy democracy
is a threat to their ideology democracy
is a threat to their power
we the pro-democracy Coalition are a
threat to them
and they want a 1930 style solution and
they are they are yelling it from the
rooftops the quiet part is way out loud
we'll [__] around and find out
Republicans because we're here and we're
not going anywhere we [__] believe in
democracy and we will stand for
democracy and we will fight at the
ballot for our democracy I know you will
I know I will let's do it together
everyone stick around we'll be right
back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babel Maga Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
foreign
this is the Tony Michaels podcast
oh boy it's Wednesday Wednesday it's
hump day you know what that means we're
seeing some karaoke tonight I want to
thank Peter Rogers
Mike Farley
[Music]
Angela Matt
others here who have bought shots in the
last week I plan on going and doing some
Shots tonight so
if you guys want to buy some more shots
just go to the Tony michaels.com it's
right there at the top right there by
Tony a shot right at the very top if you
want me to do shots tonight while I'm
singing my guts out
at karaoke we're gonna have some fun
tonight we always have fun karaoke we're
gonna do some karaoke for the show
we did one back in March or April I
believe we're gonna do we're gonna start
doing once a month I think
and I think our first karaoke show live
on Twitch we're gonna do it on Twitch
is going to be the third Sunday in
October
that's what we're gonna do the third
Sunday in October I'm gonna do karaoke
we're new Kamikaze karaoke you'll be
able to show up if you're on patreon
you'll get a chance to sign up to be on
screen with me so you'll be able to
appear on screen with me ask me
questions talk to me
and and the whole world will be able to
see on Twitch and on Discord too but you
guys will be able to make song requests
for me to sing and you'll be able to buy
me shots and I'll probably be actually
doing shots during
during that show it's bound to be a
great great time so don't forget we're
going to be doing that uh the third week
in October so rather you want to get in
on the fun on patreon go join patreon
just go to the Tony michaels.com you can
find the patreon link there or or you
can just hang out on Twitch go follow me
on Twitch if you got an Amazon account
tie it to your Twitch link those two the
directions are on the Tony michaels.com
and give your one free subscription that
you have with twitch to the Tony
Michaels podcast and then you'll be able
to watch it commercial free on Twitch
that's right we're gonna do it on Twitch
and the reason why is because when I do
it on YouTube
they they [__] cut it out because I
use YouTube videos to sing and you know
what what are you gonna do [__] them
so so I am
so we're gonna do it on Twitch so they
can't really [__] with me that much and
and Discord it'll be on Discord too so
go join the Discord join the twitch so
you go to twitch.tv slash the Tony
Michaels or you go to the Tony
michaels.com find the link there and you
can join the Discord as well it's where
the chat never stops just go to the Tony
michaels.com you'll find the Discord
link there or you know what I'll just
stick it in the chat here why not
here is the Discord link right here in
the chat there we go boom go join the
Discord server they're they're all live
chatting right now
they're talking right now
in the live chat on Discord that's right
there's a live chat on Discord the nice
part about the Discord chat live is that
you can post uh you know like memes and
Gifts in there you don't you can't you
can do more than just type so it's a
little more interactive if you want to
know the truth and then just like the
YouTube chat but whatever suits your
fancy whether you like the chat over on
Twitch you like to be here on YouTube
Facebook or you want to be over on
Discord
it's up to you
um someone asked in the chat here if I
rap
are you asking do I rap or can I rap
because let me let me find this question
here I I just had it but that's that's
the problem with my chat a lot of people
don't think I'm watching the chat but it
goes so fast
it goes so fast because I I'm seeing
Facebook YouTube twitch all in one thing
so you imagine how fast it is if you're
on one platform and then you know just
like triple that so it's very fast so
it's hard for me to keep up with
sometimes and to keep up with them
oh my God the the gifts that they're
posting but someone asked if I can rap
I mean I can do I I mean not that often
everyone knows that I'm you know kind of
fond of country music on yes
you know what I mean kind of fond of it
we got a lot of Clips to get to today
but you know what we should do we
haven't we haven't shot this [__] in a
while uh so if you got a question we'll
shoot this [__] for a little bit while
I'm I'm pulling up these clips of this
crazy uh a [__] Committee hearing today
where they're talking about Hunter Biden
Hunter bad Hunter bad and hundred bad
and they hate Weiss oh my God Weiss is
all deep State now
yeah now that now that he's you know
he's all deep State and it was funny
because he wasn't deep State then he was
deep State then he became special
counsel and then indicted Hunter Biden
on some [__] gun charges and now
they're they're struggling with rather
he's still deep state or not it's
[__] weird stuff and they're like oh
God I want to be mad about my
interpretation of the Second Amendment
and these charges get Hunter Biden but
I've got Hunter hogged syndrome so I
can't
really weird stuff
it's weird stuff it's weird stuff
um also today is Wednesday and usually
well it will become a normal schedule
that Gabe will follow me on when Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday and but he will not
be here today he is out and about
um Texas Paul couldn't join us yesterday
he had something in an engagement that
he had to that he had to take care of
next week Paul won't be with us with
either so he's taking a little bit of
vacation from the show for a couple
weeks and then he'll be back on yeah so
you got me for the entire two hours
today don't leave good God don't leave
just because it's just me
I know I'm not as good looking as Gabe
Sanchez I can grow a better beard than
him but I understand that I'm not quite
as good looking as Gabe Sanchez
um what's my height I don't know I I'm
like six three two fifteen
that's about right I'm like six three
two fifteen hey if someone else can
[__] lie about it why can't I huh
I mean you know if if he can do it then
I can do it let's do it rule of law and
order in this country
yeah I mean 6 3 2 15. no I'm just
kidding I'm not anywhere near that
um why why would you want to know my
I can have asked a question here and
Kenneth I've already asked I've already
answered that and you can go back and
watch my answer there he's talking about
Facebook why aren't ironing mine as such
anymore it it it's not that big of a
story it really isn't I wish it was a
groundbreaking story but it's not but
I've answered the question before on the
show you can go you can go check that
out
it's it's not really big of a deal it
really isn't it let's see what else do
we get
um
artsy says Tony I saw Lucas kunson Brian
Tyler Cohen the other day yeah I'm I'm
planning on getting um I'm praying I'm
planning on getting Lucas on the show
don't worry Lucas is going to come on
the show eventually we'll get we'll get
him on we'll get him on the show
um
Amos is sad that Gabe is not here I know
I know Cynthia says Gabe is a cutie
that's probably you know it is it is
it is
uh big Stefan says 632-15 I knew it
that's it right I mean anyone who's
anybody is
6 3 2 15.
you know what I mean
um Jim Jim Williams uh great moderator
says they've caught the car now what
well I'm gonna show you now what with
some of these clips
it's [__] incredible
how much they just face plant
face first and to the point
and that's it
um
why why Trump thinks Biden is going to
lead us to World War II well
number one he's a bonehead so he doesn't
know what he's talking about but again I
I want you guys to focus when Trump says
something or when Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan says something or Matt
venmo Gant said something or Jim Q Anon
Comer says something or Ted Cancun Cruz
says something they're not talking to us
the people who have enough brain cells
to realize these people are [__]
Liars grifters
and frauds
we know this okay we know this they're
talking to the flock
they're lying to the Sheep
they're herding sheep with their lies
they know they're they know they're not
going to hurt us
we're not sheep
but they have to lie to keep hurting
them up
they have to keep the lines going right
or else did it all fall out from
underneath them
um so the why Trump thinks Biden is
going to lead us to World War II he says
that [__] because the Sheep need to hear
that
this is how fascism works
okay it's not fashion Works
um Evelyn ask her when's my birthday
it's in March we got a ways to go we got
a ways to go why you want to buy me a
gift
I'll take a gift
I'm gonna last year on my birthday I
don't if you guys remember this and
there might be some new folks here that
weren't around on my last birthday holy
[__] I barely made it on the show the
next day
oh my God I I probably drank a whole
bottle of Jaeger all by myself
friends at the bar people at the bar
just kept buying me buying me Jaeger
shots for my birthday I might have been
stoned as well it's a possibility I'm
not gonna say yay or nay on to that
but but the thing is I was totally
wasted
um I had to get up the next morning and
do the show I did this I did the show
Full two hours I think I was by myself
almost that whole day
skip over on the Discord says Jaeger
monster
yeah I like Jager I like Jager a lot of
people most people do not most people
know
um let's see
what else do we have here
Chris Chris asked my mom's oh yeah great
great I am okay yeah
you guys are trying to hack into my [__]
do I sing any Kenny Rogers songs yes I
do Peter I've seen Kenny Rogers
um of course you know the Gambler of
course the great one but the one I like
is the greatest
uh the song the greatest where he's
singing about a little boy standing in a
field throwing the ball up in the air
and trying to hit it with a bat
it's a great song it's a great story of
a song
um and it's it it should be more of a
Kenny Rogers top top top five uh but I
sing that song I like that one
other questions do you guys have here
for me I like shoot the [__] this is one
of the best things
um why didn't they take his height and
weight in Fulton County isn't that a
requirement oh we're back on the height
and weight thing well it is Rob but they
let himself report it
for time timeliness they negotiated
timeliness and so he self-reported
that's how they work that in
and I'm telling you there is a two-tier
justice system
who else in Fulton County gets to
self-report their height and weight huh
and you're telling me that there's not a
two-tier justice system and he's not a
beneficiary of that two-tier justice
system give me a [__] break the
reason why Republicans are pissed off
the reason why Maga is pissed off about
the two-tier justice system is because
the two-tier justice system is not
protecting Trump the way they want
that's it Patsy says I love your show I
love you being here Pat keep continue
being here I love having every single
one of you here
um
uh okay uh Caitlin Caitlyn here on
Facebook says Tony do you think
McChicken I I'm thinking you're saying
McCarthy that's good McChicken will
capitulate and make a deal with Dems
after about a week of shutdown secondly
if they try to bounce him they will
never get the votes okay so here's the
thing all right think about this in the
context of really what is possible not
not what the media tells you
all right so I'm going to show you a
clip today of a republican from New York
basically saying Maga is out of their
minds right
which is opening the door to Kevin
McCarthy to go to one of his choices
he's got two choices here and only two
and it's only because Kevin McCarthy
sold his speakership he sold it off he's
not actually the speaker he just
controls that office right he's not
actually the speaker
the Maga wing of the Republican caucus
is the speaker that's why I'm Matt yet
and Trump really is the speaker here if
you want to know the honest truth
that's what Matt gets the whole thing is
is he's going out and Performing this
theater to push along Kevin McCarthy to
do Donald Trump's bidding in the house
without that
let's rewind
do you remember when John Boehner was a
speaker
you remember that he would cry and SOB
every time someone said my daddy's
barred
you remember this guy
the one thing the one thing
that the at the time the Tea Party you
remember the tea party which became Maga
hated about John Boehner is John Boehner
would not genuine flick to them
um it's one reason why when John Boehner
went to give up his speakership Kevin
McCarthy was supposed to be the next in
line but that bonehead went on national
television and said the quiet part out
loud which at the time was not okay now
it's fine they can say the quiet part
out loud the Nazi cat is out of the bag
okay they're like no we're we're really
we're kind of we're like being fascist
so we're just gonna be fascists right
the manga won the Civil War inside the
Republican Party the fascist one the
Nazis won
but Kevin McCarthy at the time back then
before manga had won that Civil War
had said yeah the reason why we had the
Benghazi hearings was to hurt Hillary
Clinton's campaign and it worked that's
what he said and they were like dude you
can't [__] say that you're you can't
be the speaker and say that type of [__]
you got to be smarter than that well
he's really stupid he's dumb as dog [__]
McChicken that is McCarthy
hey here's the thing
so we fast forward to now right and
Kevin McCarthy had to genuflect to Trump
to get Trump to tell those
representatives to vote for him and the
theater went on for a week we covered it
here for a goddamn week
we can't show in the hearings and it was
just the vote after vote at is [__]
ridiculous really
that Trump would would just not hand it
to McCarthy but he finally did he
finally did
and the one thing that they're really
pissed off about with McCarthy is he
handed
he handed the debt ceiling to Joe Biden
because Joe Biden the Democrats tricked
him and they do they kind of want the
same thing here
they kind of want the same thing here
but they're going to follow Trump
they're going to follow Trump if Trump
wants to shut the government down it's
going to be shut down as long as Trump
wants the government shutdown it's going
to be shut down
because Kevin McCarthy is not the
Speaker of the House
he's in the office but his balls
reside at Mar-A-Lago
and all Donald Trump has to do is
squeeze him just a little bit just a
little bit
now ultimately will Kevin McCarthy
remain speaker yes he will remain
speaker through this process and the
reason why he remain speakers because
he's going to do anything to keep his
job
including capitulating to Donald Trump
and the Mongol wing of his party now
he's got to leave the door open to both
options because he's only got two he
only has two choices here
he can either be with his party and shut
down the government and keep it shut
down until Trump says open it or he can
side with the Democrats bring it to the
floor bring a CR to the floor that the
Democrats will vote on and a handful of
Republicans and he can win that vote and
he can keep the government open
he'll lose his seat as Speaker he will
not be the speaker anymore
but he will keep the government open
so what advantage does Kevin McCarthy
have deciding with Democrats
what advantage
other than when Trump decides that it's
hurting him
to not have the government open to tell
Kevin McCarthy to go side with the
Democrats so any kind of sense
that Kevin McCarthy and the House
Republicans are somehow going to side
with with Democrats that's all theater
that's all theater to make sure when the
time comes that they need to open the
government
when the orange Mussolini Jesus the guy
who holds the speaker's balls down at
Mar-A-Lago or bet Minster whichever one
he he carries around Kevin McCarthy's
balls like he carries around classified
documents right
that
that is when they will deploy his second
strategy his second choice which is to
side with Democrats to get the
government open so that Republicans
aren't blame for it anymore and
Democrats will do it right because
Democrats want to govern
and yes it's bad it's bad narrative
but it's also good for the country so
they'll do it they don't you know
Democrats care more about the country
and the Democrats and their constituents
than they do about [__] Optics and
narrative and Power
they just do
and the reason why is because they
believe in democracy
they don't [__] want to use democracy
to destroy our Republic
okay what else do we got here
oh man do we have any more questions I
lost you guys went on a tan I went on a
tangent here and lost track of the chat
so if you've got any questions throw
them in the chat there now we're
shooting the [__] we're going to shoot
the [__] up to the top of the hour and
then I'm going to show you some of these
clips that are coming out of this
Committee hearing today and why it's so
ridiculous and you should be excited
about what's going on
oh my God the one where Matt dance is
absolutely just stuffed in a locker oh
it's beautiful
it's immutable it's beautiful
now a lot of people aren't going to be
happy about Merrick Garland's
performance today and you know I I
understand that
um because Merrick Garland isn't the
best at performing in these situations
um he he's not he's a better judge than
he is in ag but he's a damn good ag2 and
the reason why is because he was a judge
that's one reason why he's a a fairly
decent AG but he's just not good in
these committee hearings as we'd like
him to be if that makes sense
like he's he's just not as uh he doesn't
you know
he doesn't really punch back as hard
right he didn't punch back as hard as
we'd want
um he tries to really you know
stay with balls and strengths
but really they're not getting what they
want out of him which is the sound bites
right
they want the sound bites to sound like
for for Trader TV news networks this
afternoon and this evening
and going on that
um they really they really want
this narrative that that Merrick Garland
is somehow
protecting Hunter Biden under Joe
Biden's directive and that he's
Prosecuting Trump under Jill Biden's
directive which is not the case at all
just not not even close
um and just by the questioning that is
happening you can tell that that's not
the case
but it doesn't it's not going to deter
them from their Nazi propaganda
and their Nazi messaging because they're
[__] victims here and there we're
victims oh we're the victims
and they speak fluent victims the
Republican Party
so it really is not surprising
um what they're doing
uh James asked did I did I see Denver
reporter Tara Bobo to shred yeah I've
seen this but it
I mean
I've tore her to shreds
what the [__] does it matter of a Denver
reporter tears her to shreds or not I
mean I yeah I get the I get the content
and I get the context right
but I mean
the thing is is that Lauren bobert
literally won by less than 500 votes in
her District this last time
um it is likely that if she wins this
time it'll be much fewer than 500 it'll
be so close
and if she if she if she wins right
that's how close it is in that District
you just got to get people to to
participate in the election
and go to the ballot and use the ballot
as their weapon to make sure they get
decent representation instead of some
some [__] blaming blaming her
indiscretions which honestly folks I'm
I'm not I'm what she did in the theater
is not even close to the top of the list
of why this person should not be in
Congress like not even [__] close not
even close to the top there's so many
other [__] things about her
that are way more Despicable
than her her playing
with some guy's hogged through his pants
at Beetlejuice
and he's honking her Hooters okay it's
just so much more before that
that makes this person not qualified to
be even on the city council let alone
our United States Congress okay
so I mean again I know I know the bobert
thing is really you know it's really fun
to go after and she's a [__] liar I
mean really the lying about it is more
egregious than you know what she did in
the theater we're just like I wouldn't
Vape it no no no and that's our first
date and I and and he's a Democrat so I
dumped him apparently they had been
having sex for a long time apparently I
don't know I know what people are saying
is they've been having sex for a long
time her and this dude that was in the
theater
and and and the right wing is trying to
make this into somehow this guy was
sexually assaulting her in the theater
are you [__] [__] me
come on man if she if he's sexually
assaulting her she's sexually assaulting
him I don't know if you watch the
[__] video
but she's honking on his hog as much as
she she's honking on her Hooters
no question
that video does not depict him or her
being assaulted
it is consensual and it is obvious that
it is consensual in the video
I mean if they weren't in a public space
I would say there would have been a lot
more going on
than just the hands right
but again but again it's the hypocrisy
it's not really the act of it I don't I
you know PDA is one thing right some
people like to have pdas some people
don't like PDA some people are grossed
out by it some people don't give a [__]
I mean but you know what
to each his own they weren't they
weren't getting naked he didn't get it
out as far as you can tell on the video
I mean he looked like he desperately
wanted you know
her Hooters out
I will say I will say other than the
Denver reporter blasting Lauren bobert
Howard Stern's take on it
is [__] incredible and you should go
if you're gonna go listen to the Denver
reporters take on it you should go
listen to Howard Sterns
ow because he's he's spot on and and
another one that you need to look at
that we showed on the show here and was
was Trey Crowder the liberal redneck so
I don't know I just I just I feel like
like honestly
the [__] she did in the theater is not
even close to the [__] that we should be
saying that what is disqualifying for
her to be a congressperson like that's
so far down on the list of [__]
so far down on a list of [__]
dude you got any more questions when
we're getting to the top of the hour
we're gonna get to some of these clips
from the hearing and the reason why I'm
holding off is because I know I know
it's gonna because I want the swallow
Eclipse to be there we're gonna I'm
gonna show you um
clips of Merit Garland's opening
statement I'm going to show you clips of
Steve Cohen absolutely dunking Mac ants
in the trash that's a great one and I'm
sure there's some swallow clips that
will show and he was talking as I came
on at least that's what I was listening
to because I think I had it I had a I
had it paused for a little bit because I
was getting the show ready
um but we're gonna we're gonna get to
those clips and I'm just giving you a
little bit of time to get some of these
clips out and so that we can go grab
them and watch them some of these clips
are going to be like I I haven't even
seen them yet we're gonna watch them
together
um
meowza Howard Stern of all people that
talk about it yeah well no no I'm
telling you go listen to what Howard
says about it
because Howard's I mean he's kind of
saying the same thing I'm saying like
look
you know if you want to get horny and
all sexed up in public as long as you're
not being indecent and exposing yourself
you know PDA whatever in fact whatever
but don't don't be [__] saying people
can't dress a certain way and certain
people can't go to certain places want
wanting wanting to annihilate an entire
a group of people of our countrymen
lgbtq people because you think they're
demons or some [__]
I mean I mean honestly she thinks it's
okay for her and a man to be
consensually grabbing each other in the
theater but a woman and a woman or a man
and a man oh my God she wouldn't want to
Outlaw that she'd want to arrest him
she'd want to charge him with felonies
and she'd probably want to give him the
Rhonda Santa's treatment of execution on
site no due process of law I mean she's
a Nazi that's what I have to assume like
you got to go there you got to start
there first what do you want from me
what do you want from me they're they're
people running for their leader of their
party are saying execute people without
due process of law that's what Rhonda
Sanchez is saying okay they're [__]
Nazis and he won't decry the Nazis that
are standing on overpasses and and
protesting Disney in Florida so I have
to assume I have to assume that Rhonda
santis is a [__] Nazi
he didn't like her costume and I have to
assume because Lauren bobert has
supported Rhonda Santos in the past said
he would make a great president so I'm
only assuming that she would do the same
thing
I haven't heard her speak out against
Ron DeSantis
and his words about you know executing
people without due process of law
so but Howard gives a good rendition of
it
and it's it's kind of funny
what else we got we got just a few more
minutes here of shoot the [__] oh yeah
um Liz says she loves Eric swalwell
Eric swallow does a very good job in
committee hearings most of the time
um Deidre says Garland is looking at
them like what the [__] because a lot of
the questions are like what the [__]
what the what the [__] are you talking
about
and and they know he you know there's
certain aspects of this case these cases
that Garland has not dove into like one
question was why why are you have you
told the president United States to
knock it off the doj
the doj has the doj went to the
president United States and told him to
knock it off and he's like what the [__]
are you knock what off what are you
talking about
he's like letting Hunter Biden in the
White House
and mayor Gardens like we don't go tell
the president he can't do anything I'm
I'm not a person that goes and tells the
president what he can and can't do
that's not my [__] job what the [__]
are you talking to him we prosecute
crimes
David Weiss was that it was a U.S
attorney in Delaware Trump appointed him
to investigate Hunter Biden we knew that
and we knew that we couldn't get rid of
him because it was a political Witch
Hunt and we're looking more political if
we got rid of him so we let him stay
there and we trusted him so much so that
we aim in special counsel privileges
against Hunter Biden and the Biden
family and he found nothing other than
some gun charges some [__] gun
charges when you interpret it through a
two-way bro interpretation of the Second
Amendment the [__] out of here
uh Norma says uh is Nadler in the clip
there's nadler's in the couple of Clips
I don't know if I'll play any Clips with
navler in it
um
um again I I believe Goldman is in the
couple of Clips but he's more telling
Jim Jordan why he's an idiot and why he
doesn't know how to run a hearing it's
more points of order
um basically Goldman pointing out that
oh happy
Jim Jordan Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan is a [__] idiot that he is
let's see here uh do we have any more
questions
um did have I have ever been to Grant's
Farm in the Clydesdales scene yeah I've
I've drove past Grant's Farm and I've
been to a couple of Clydesdale farms uh
here in Missouri they have several
Clydesdale Farms here in Missouri
are some of them that you can go take
tours of but they're not as they're not
as popular and famous as Grant's Farm in
St Louis yeah I've seen the client's
tales
and they're talking about Budweiser the
Budweiser Clydesdales
uh everyone knows I'm from Missouri and
live here in Missouri so
let's see what other questions do we
have what other questions do we have uh
we're gonna get to the top of the hour
here we're gonna come back we're gonna
watch some of these clips from this
[__] hearing
and we're gonna watch
representative from Tennessee Stephen
Cohen dunk Matt Getz in the trash so
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
foreign
[Music]
and I'm going to show you this clip from
representative Stephen Cohen from
Tennessee it's fantastic
you're not going to get much better than
this
um it's only 17 seconds but that's
really all
Stephen Cohen needed
to absolutely dunk
Matt gants in the trash let's go to that
let's go to that clip here here it is
let's listen to it see if I can get the
volume right take care of that
shoot him
[__] department does not make comments
about its Investments we're not
weaponized if we're weaponized we'd have
done it that was a Beautiful Exchange
there it shows we didn't do take care
oh you want you want proof of
weaponization oh there you go there's
your proof there you go America's like
oh [__] oh man we're getting into the
we're getting into the [__] uh so
there's Stephen Cohen there absolutely
dunking Matt Gantz in the trash
and uh again Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan does not know how to
handle a hearing
the one thing that Jim Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan would do is to
make sure that [__] didn't come up in a
hearing
he doesn't do it they have no clue
they're flying by the seat of their
pants or the lack of a jacket I mean
really honestly this is ridiculous I
mean
what's next is Jim Jordan going to wear
a hoodie is he going to wear a hoodie in
these as the chairman in these
committees Jesus Christ we know that
only Traders wear hoodies right
this should be [__] news
you know what I mean this should be oh
the goddamn this should be new what is
Jim Jordan gonna wear start wearing
hoodies he can't wear a jacket he can't
stick to a dress code are you kidding me
this is ridiculous he's going to take
his tie off and he's going to be wearing
a t-shirt then that [__] is
going to be wearing a hoodie what a
traitor
there's Jim Jordan is
here
remember yesterday oh man whoo John
fetterman John fetterman wearing a
hoodie that was the biggest piece of
news on Trader TV news networks is how
John fetterman wears hoodies okay yeah
okay
all right let me show you this news from
Texas and then we'll get back to the um
I got a couple of Texas things I want to
take care of here real quick real quick
before we get into more house hearings I
just wanted to show you that um
a clip of Stephen Cohen uh here's Ben
Collins
on Twitter he says um this apology to a
Houston School District sent to parents
for assigning
an illustrated version of Anne Frank's
diary to students the teacher was fired
for assigning it that's right you heard
it correctly
I'm not I'm not [__] you you are my
favorite turd
I would not [__] you
they fired a teacher
for assigning
students to read an illustated version
of Anne Frank's diary
here's the statement the reading of that
content will cease immediately your
student's teacher will communicate her
apologies to you and your students soon
and she has expressed those apologies to
us
I wonder I wonder if they were wearing
swastika bands when she was apologizing
to them
I wonder I don't know I'm just surmising
here I don't know
I would say they were probably not to
uniform when this happened
wouldn't you
here's the thing
here's what I said and this is the
[__] truth about all this [__] on
education this mom's for Liberty these
[__] with casseroles the Taliban in
a minivan right
these moms for Hitler
the reason why they want Anne Frank's
diary and other books out of schools and
out of curriculum isn't because they're
offended
this isn't about being offended it's
about erasing history so they can repeat
it
Republicans want a 1930 style solution
full stop
I'm not being hyperbolic
this is what they want
they want to erase history so they can
repeat it go look at project 2025 which
we're gonna do by the way that's one
reason why you need to go follow the
library democracy
we're going to be doing a lot of content
over there that shows you
the back and forth
and the comparison of 1930s Germany
and this project 2025.
so go follow and get the library of
democracy's YouTube channel to a
thousand subscribers
it's at almost 900 right now we just
need over a hundred people
to go subscribe to that Channel that I
just put in the chat to get over a
thousand so go subscribe right now
we're gonna make up plenty of videos on
how to engage and how to use
their plan
to erase history and repeat it against
them
because that's what they are trying to
do they they're not offended they're not
offended by this [__]
they're not offended
they're worried if they don't convince
people that this if they don't erase
this history quick fast and in a hurry
that they won't be able to repeat it and
they want to repeat it and if we know
that this history exists they will not
be able to repeat it
I'm going to be doing a lot of content
here and talking about project 2025 and
they're not in the Republican party's
Nazi plans
but there's going to be plenty of
correlation that's going to happen in
library democracy backed up by facts
to show you
what their 1930 style solution will be
so make sure you go follow the library
of democracy it's very important that we
expose these [__] not just in
content like mine
but also
giving everything
[Music]
um
is that a YouTube channel someone asked
the library thing that is yes it's in
the chat there you can go to YouTube and
just type in at library of democracy you
can type in the library democracy or you
can hit the link or you can go to the
tonymichaels.com
and hit the link of the library of
democracy but you definitely are going
to want to follow the library of
democracy because not only is it going
to provide a lot of content and exposing
project 2025 of what it truly is
historically
but also
also you will find plenty of videos
Quick videos on how to engage rapidly
easily you'll be able to share them with
people because I I know that that's the
thing you know they're on the library of
democracy for a minute and the goal of
the library democracy over there their
goal with the library of democracy is to
kind of glue all the resources together
that already exist the left the left and
pro-democracy people have a lot of
resources at their fingertips
there's just no one out there pointing
out showing you which ones are which
they're all kind of working in concert
separately we want them to work in
concert together so we can advance our
democracy right
and that's what the library democracy
mission is
is to be the glue to glue all those
resources together in one place for you
so you can go engage in your democracy
and combat fascism anywhere you can on
the battleground of the ballot
and using using what is the truth
to advance our democracy
um foggy Ozark asks a questionnaire will
democracy survive project 2025 that's up
to us
that's a good question but that's up to
us
I mean if we if we let project 2025
exist because right now it's just an
idea and it'll be an idea forever the
problem is that the cat's out of the bag
the Republican party is finally admitted
what we've known for a lot what I've
known for a long time they're a bunch of
[__] Nazis
and they and they want 1930 style
solutions for people they don't like in
this country
especially dissenters like you and me
and like people who want to know the
truth about Anne Frank
and how the Nazis were exterminated
in Hitler's Germany they don't want you
to know that and it's not that they
don't want you to know that because they
don't want you to they want to repeat it
here
they have to erase that history so we
don't know it so that they can repeat it
right
it's what they're doing
that's what they're going to continue to
do so will our democracy survive project
2025 if as long as I have anything to do
about it you goddamn write it will
because I'm not going to hold back
there's no one that can tell me to hold
back not a goddamn person the reason why
this microphone exists and it's on is
because of you
we're totally independent here
I said the Nazis I meant the I meant
Nazis Exterminating Jews
dissent the scent is what drives
democracy and you must have dissent
and we have we must we must muster up
the courage to have a level of dissent
that we've never seen before against
project 2025 and the ideas in it more
than just the document the idea is in it
and I'm telling you I've got I've I've
got people working to show us
show us exactly
how this Compares historically
not just necessarily to Nazi Germany in
the 1930s because who baby did they lift
a lot of Hitler's plans
but also the Middle East
in their fascist theocracies there
they're trumpeting it out loud now and
and you can't stuff that Nazi cat back
in the bag once it's out
so
we will expose them here on this show
and we will continue to do it over and
over and over again but the only concern
you should have about project 2025 is
your own engagement against it
that's what your concern should be
how engaged are we against it
and we're going to give you we're going
to give you all the ammo you need
here on this show I'm going to give you
all
the ammo I can give you
to go back to it to engage in your
democracy against it to win
at The Ballot Box
it was really dumb of them to produce it
to be quite honest it was really stupid
for them to write that [__] out and then
and then make it public it really was
dumb
I mean if they really wanted this to be
the plan what they should have done is
kept it secret
but they made it to our people like me
who won't shut the [__] up
to know about it and that's bad for them
because I'm not Beholder to anyone no
one
besides you the audience who wants the
truth
that's what we must do
we must know the truth and we must use
the truth to go out and fight the battle
of the ballot and engage in our
democracy and use that strategic outrage
so
okay let's see here oh again one more
time go follow the library of democracy
for me let me put that in the chat
here
stay with me here all right so go follow
that YouTube channel
there's a couple videos there now and
there's going to be more videos released
this week I think and next week so go
follow the channel the library of
democracy right now on YouTube uh you're
going to want to see that content and
you're going to want to see the
development of the library of democracy
I know you are let's see where we're at
we're at 907 we need less than a hundred
we need less than a hundred
less than a hundred that's all we need
is less than 100 to get to get the
library of democracy
to a thousand so thank you very much for
doing that I know our goal is yesterday
but we're going to reach it today I have
a feeling that's what that's the problem
with goldstead 914. see look at this you
people are the best people in the world
uh and you know what the library of
democracy promotes
The Illustrated version
of Anne Frank's diary so students know
the [__] truth
so they know the truth so history does
not have to repeat itself
that's the key that's the key all right
better than now Texas news I got another
clip for you here speaking of Texas news
um the Lou's Cruise pack I kind of like
that name the Lew's Cruise pack
I don't know they put out a pretty good
ad here
um so let's watch this new ad they put
out against
Ted podcast cruise I mean Cancun Cruise
or is it podcast cruise I don't know you
decide some of y'all know I do every
week a podcast I do every week a podcast
I do a podcast every week I do the
podcast three days a week I do a podcast
I do a podcast I do a podcast last year
I launched a podcast two years ago I
launched a podcast three years ago I
launched a podcast I do a podcast my
last podcast today's podcast on the
podcast podcast or my podcast back to
catanji Brown Jackson's confirmation
hearing you know a couple of years ago I
was doing my weekly podcast my podcast
my podcast my podcast my podcast my
podcast my podcast my podcast podcast
the podcast podcast podcast
[Music]
if you're a grifter you got a grift
but I mean it is true it is true of your
grifter you got a grip so why wouldn't
you be grifting uh here's the thing
again I am not opposed to Ted Cruz
having a podcast frankly I wish Ted Cruz
would do his podcast every [__] day
not three days a week not once a week
not what are you some kind of [__] you
can't do a podcast every single day huh
what
I do one every day why can't he oh
that's right because he's got a job to
do
and he falls down on his job and doesn't
doesn't represent his constituents in
the entire state of Texas because he's
too concentrated on promoting his
podcast
well here's the thing Ted go do your
[__] podcast and leave the rest of us
alone
just resign in disgrace because that's
what you are as a disgrace
you're a member of the Maga Trader party
just go do your show man no I mean no
one will literally listen to you but
whatever go do your show
leave us the [__] alone
oh my God Ted Cruz are you kidding me
okay let me show you another thing about
um Rachel bidikoff or my friend Dr
Rachel whitakoffer and you guys you guys
are huge fans of Dr Rachel cover she
tweeted something this morning now I
don't normally show you polls
here on the on the show I'm gonna show
you polls or anything like that any
[__] but I'm gonna show you this
poll because this one really does matter
this one really matters
it's one that actually counts this poll
counts
Rachel posted special election in New
Hampshire state house saw the Democrat
take a former Republican held District
by 12 points
listen to the signal not the noise it's
beautiful here's the results right here
a Democrat beats a Republican
in a New Hampshire State House seat
this is the only poll that matters folks
this is the poll that matters
it doesn't matter what [__] dumbass
fake up rig polls that they had about
this race before it doesn't matter what
the pundit said about the polls before
it only matters
what the poll says at The Ballot Box
what the polls say at The Ballot Box
that's it that's the only pull that
matters
and Dr Rachel minikoffers spot on
listen to the signal not the noise
just what's gonna have to happen
in this country
you're gonna have to stop listening to
the media you're going to stop when they
when they show a [__] poll on air
oh and someone says show us again are
you wanting the the actual the result
here's the result here you go here's the
result right here
Republican 44 Democrat
55 well almost 56 100 reported
huge
percentage of margin I mean it's a house
race so there's not very many people
voting in a special election that's the
other thing we got to solve
right here this poll you got to believe
this
this is this is the this is the proof
this is the real poll
only 1500 people went and voted against
the Republican and 1240 voted for about
a Nazi I mean I have to assume they got
an our next student name what else am I
supposed to assume
I mean if you don't want me to assume
these type of things maybe you should
fix your party
but these are the only polls that matter
2024 is going to be only pull that
matters
all right
now let's go so that's Texas news New
Hampshire news
let's see if we can um
I gotta show that yeah I want to add
here's more Texas news I don't know I'm
not gonna go there I'll be in that
rabbit hole forever let's show this
you know Charlie Kirk
oh my God the cognitive dissidents of
Charlie Kirk is beautiful and really
honestly the cognitive dissidents of the
Republicans is beautiful here's the
reason why
I have said this time and time again
that their delusion is going to be
Donald Trump's ultimate downfall
like they actually believe some of this
[__] Charlie Kirk is saying angry
indoctrinated college women will ruin
America if we let them remember I said
earlier here's here's a bunch of people
yelling
Aunt Charlie Kirk because he showed up
at some college
and he did this on purpose right because
they were protesting him
right
so he wanted this imagery that they're
yelling at him
but what he doesn't understand
is all these women here they can vote
and they should and they probably will
gen Z has proven to us time and time
again in the last couple years that they
are willing not to just yell and scream
about democracy but they believe in it
so much
that they will go and use their power of
the ballot and vote
so I hope they keep going with this
stupid [__]
are you serious and angry women are
going to ruin America if we let it
listen to what he's saying
listen to the tuberville message that
he's got there okay listen to it
college women will ruin America he
doesn't want women to go to college
that's what he's saying
he does not want women to go to college
that's what he's [__] saying and his
cognitive dissonance oh baby
keep going
keep going because I believe the women
in this country College age or otherwise
are going to stand up for their [__]
rights
and I believe that there's allies out
there in the country that are going to
continue to stand up for their for those
College women's rights but that's that's
what Charlie Kirk is saying
I mean it's the same thing Tommy too
revealing some of these other
Republicans like Mike Pence and and Ron
DeSantis are saying about abortion in
the military
they're not talking about abortion in
the military they don't want women in
the military
that's what they're saying
trust me they're gonna I mean they
aren't saying it yet like that but
they're gonna get there
they're gonna get there because these
Nazi [__] right-wing commentators
like Nick Fuentes Charlie Kirk are going
to push them there that's what Charlie's
doing with the whole well these [__]
women in colleges man they're a problem
women in college
right
they're and the Republicans are going to
start saying gonna start trying to
legislate in States in counties
they're going to start trying to pull
funding from colleges
then make sure that women have a fair
shot to get into their schools I'm
telling you it's gonna happen
if we don't do something about it which
is to fire all these [__] feckless
fascists
well
speaking of feckless fascist let's talk
about House Republicans here's a press
conference yesterday
of them
bashing each other the civil war with
Maga continues let's listen political
is for Optics out of fear
appointed I am pissed off this is not
a conservative republicanism this is
stupidity
the idea that we're going to shut the
government down
when we don't control the Senate we
don't control the White House these
people can't define a win they don't
know how to take yes for an answer uh
it's a clown show you keep running
lunatics you're going to be in this
position he's not talking about
Democrats they're not talking about
Democrats okay they're talking about
[__] Republicans that's a lunatics
that they're talking about
because there's some inside their party
that have to run in districts that Biden
won okay this is not because these
Republicans have some sort of [__]
conscience that's like saying Mitt
Romney has the conscience get the [__]
out of here with that [__] Mitt Romney
is the guy who strapped his dog to the
top of a car he's the one who talked
about binders of women
as if that's where women belong not in
college not in the military in binders
where they belong right you remember
this Mitt Romney come on
he's got some some sort of conscience
get the [__] out of here
just because he had his power stripped
away from him as the former nominee of
their party
because they capitulated a fascist
the type of fascism that he really truly
loves I mean the dude wears the dude
wears special kinds of underwear okay
and I'm not against that hey whatever
you want to do whatever floats your boat
Mitt Romney whatever kind of underwear
you want to wear fine just don't be
telling other people what kind of
underwear they can [__] wear okay got
it
got it
but they're not they don't have a
conscience here
they don't have a conscience here what
is happening
what is happening is that they want to
remain in Congress they want their power
so they have to start turning against
Maga and you want to know why you want
to know why the House Republicans are
pretending to him and meech Mitch Joe
badden we're gonna meet him
that's what Lauren bobert says she and
meech is Joe Biden just like she juices
the beetle right
the reason why they're pretending to
impeach Joe Biden is because they can't
impeach Joe Biden they cannot do it
they have to have votes to impeach
that's how it works
hey can you check to see if they need a
majority to impeach Joe bot can you
check that out for me
do we even have to say this out loud
the problem is is that Kevin McCarthy
cannot bring a vote to the floor to
impeach Joe Biden because it will fail
now I want him to bring the vote to
impeach Joe Biden to the floor that's
what I want
I want him to lose and to show the
entire country and the world how [__]
ridiculous they are
by losing a vote to even impeach Joe
Biden on the floor that's what I want
and Republicans who have to win their
seats
because Joe Biden is going to win their
District
they have to vote to not impeach him
that would be [__] beautiful and
that's what these clowns are doing
so this person who says he's a lunatic I
say the same thing anyone any Republican
Congressman who's a sitting Republican
right now in the house if you're calling
your party members lunatics and clowns
and the the party of stupidity then you
need to leave the party
anything else anything else less than
that
of leaving your party I don't care if
you become a Democrat become an
independent anything less than you
leaving your party is capitulating to
the what you call lunatics okay you're
capitulating to them and that's what
they're doing that's why it's all
theater that's why it's all [__]
again these congressmen is you know I
always say Trump and the Maga and
mongoloidites in Congress are talking to
their sheep these congressmen are trying
to talk to you
they're trying to [__] dupe you into
believing oh yeah yeah there's
reasonable Republicans there's
Republicans that think those other
idiots are lunatics
anything less than them leaving their
party is capitulation
period
listen if you have one Nazi eating
dinner at a table and you have 10 other
people sitting with that Nazi having
dinner with that Nazi there are 11 Nazis
at that table
hmm
thank you uh Christopher Webb for giving
us that mashup of a clip I appreciate
that as always Chris Webb is a good
resource
if you're gonna if you're gonna find a
resource and keep up with some of the
clips he does a great job Christopher
wood does a great job on Twitter if
you're on Twitter still
but again tuberville's defense is all
[__]
it's all [__] they don't really
believe this stuff
now some news that I missed the other
day
um as I was scurrying through the
internet
did you know
did you know that Mike Lindell gets
really pissed off I mean super pissed
when you call my pillows lumpy pillows
oh my [__] god he gets infuriated
I'm gonna show you the clip because it's
not that long of him getting pissed off
and it's funny as [__] right
it's funny and [__] but here's the thing
he went he's going bankrupt did you know
he's got a five bankruptcy
oh Mike listen buddy Mike I honestly
people were like you know for years for
years now I've been like oh Mike
lindell's a threat Mike Lindell is a
threat to our country he's a traitor
he's a criminal which he probably does
all those things right but the one thing
that Mike Lindell had
was money
and we know in this country we're
[__] greed is running rampant
especially in politics right and Mike
Lindell had a lot of power with that
money
and what Mike Lindell did is he got
duped by Trump to go spend his entire
Fortune
let me tell you a little bit of Mike
Lindell Mike Lindell is a former crack
addict which I mean you know hey a lot
of people are drug addicts some people
are addicted to booze some crack some
cigarettes some people are addicted to
other things you know not as harmful
maybe porn
um a hobby you know maybe like uh
I don't know there's a lot of hobbies
out there
the thing is is that we we
in this country watch Mike Lindell
destroy an entire portion that he built
off a right-wing radio
here's how Michael Lindell built this
Fortune he makes shitty pillows they're
shitty
were some of the worst reviews of any
Pella brand fellow out there but how
Mike Lindell made his fortune is he
advertised those shitty pillows on right
wing talk radio
that's how he made his fortune he's like
America America
and they post it all over
all over right wing talk radio and he
made a fortune because these [__]
sheep just buy whatever pukes up on
right wing talk radio
so you made a fortune on these shitty
pillows
Fortune
you know what I did with that fortune he
destroyed it for Trump
no better result ever in the history of
ever is Mike Lindell losing his entire
Fortune for Trump
to to not only not only to try to
convince people that Trump won but
proving time and time again through
spending his fortune that Trump has lost
it's incredible
it's fantastic I can't even tell you
how how much this should be a case study
in our history in the history for a
lesson
of how rich people are not smart the
amount of money does not mean equal your
amount of intelligence
it does not no [__] way can't
convince me this is a perfect case study
in that effort
Mike Lindell is a [__] bonehead
someone somewhere told him he should
advertise on right wing radio and he did
and it [__] worked and it made him a
fortune and he blew it
he blew the entire thing
on Trump on the idea that Trump [__]
won when he didn't
now does Michael Lindell actually
believe that Trump won I'm beginning to
think so
and the reason why I think Mike Glendale
believes all this garbage he was willing
to drop his entire fortune on this guy
his entire Fortune but look at all the
other people that have dropped their
entire Fortune Rudy Giuliani is [__]
broke apparently he's being sued in New
York for like a million and a half
dollars because he can't pay his [__]
attorneys
which why would any attorney defend Rudy
Giuliani without taking money up front
anyways
anybody
and they try to do a fundraiser for Rudy
Giuliani and 12 people showed up just
about as many people that showed up at
Mike lindell's uh supposedly cyber
Symposium in Springfield Missouri
you remember that
big step says same 1.4 okay all right
I'll admit I was wrong 1.5 1.4 sue me
Tony was wrong Tony was I'm just kidding
big step in
thanks for pointing that out
um but in this clip you're going to see
Mike Lindell read get really pissed when
the attorney is questioning him really
[__] pissed
when he refers to the pills as lumpy
pills watch this okay and I'm not asking
about the lumpy pillow calls no they're
not lumpy pillows that's not what they
call on okay when you say lumpy pillows
now you're an [__] you got that
you're an [__] is what you are like
no he's an [__] he's an ambulance
chasing [__] that's what you are
lumpy pillows kiss my ass put that in
your book no they answer anything any
problem customer that wants to reach
Mike Lindell those are the ones I want
to talk to Mike Lindell I want to talk
to Mike Lindell they send them to here
and they go
or they call about um maybe they didn't
get their pillow on time because of uh
um the FedEx or whatever but we'll cover
them even though it could be that
somebody else's fault nobody calls
because of a lumpy pillow a limpy pillow
an Olympic pillow no one tells because
of the lumpy pillow no they actually do
call a lot because of lumpy pills that's
one of the actual things that that
people hate about that pillow do you
know what the pillow action is you know
why it's a lumpy pillow
because they shred they shred foam so he
he buys foam as cheap as he [__] can
get it and he throws it in a shredder a
foam Shredder that's the machine they
got in his Factory a big ass foam
Shredder and it shreds the foam into
little bitty tiny pieces of foam and
then they stuff that in the pillow
and you tell me is that science or is
that just a lumpy [__] pillow
oh my God no he went bankrupt literally
went bankrupt for loyalty to Trump
you stupid bastards just keep on digging
to be quite honest with you keep going
Mike don't stop buddy keep going keep
embarrassing yourself keep embarrassing
the right wing with your [__]
um because you're doing a bang-up job I
mean you really are you really are
[__] just deluding Americans here's a
good example of just a [__] brain
dead person who's been absolutely
manipulated into believing absolute
[__] horseshit now the good liars
always with the uh with the great videos
and the great questions let's listen to
the listen to this lady
absolutely run smack dab face into
cognitive dissonance and not even
realize it watch this I don't care if he
is in a jail cell I am one of those
people that will
vote for him no matter what how do you
feel about the concept of Law and Order
in general
I
I agree with Law and Order I am 100 you
feel that if he's he's convicted though
that wouldn't change your mind be
convicted if he was but he won't but if
if he was he won't if he was convicted
he won't be convicted if he was
convicted
it is impossible no but I'm saying what
if he's found guilty he won't be but
what if he is I'm not going to answer
that question he won't be but if a trial
takes place and then he's found guilty
like what if that happens that question
okay
whoosh
I've been saying for a long time that he
was going to be the nominee and this is
just proof positive that he will be
honest can't even you can't even get
into a situation where something that's
not even hypothetical it is a realistic
possibility with 91 charges leveled
against Donald Trump in four different
jurisdictions that he will be found
guilty of at least one of them
at least one felony
this guy's gonna be convicted of now
when is that I don't I you know I don't
know it's not for me to decide it's the
court process that happens right but at
some point
at some point in our near future Donald
Trump will be found guilty of at least
one charge
out of the 91 plus because there's going
to be more charges to come I believe
there's gonna be more superseding
indictments there's going to be more
evidence of witness tampering he's
probably gonna catch charges there it's
possible he'll catch charges in Michigan
and Arizona it looks like it could be
more and more possible even as the state
fake electors the 16 people who were
charged in in Michigan are saying no
well you did it at the behest of him
he he wanted us to do it and we said yes
we'll do it
so it's possible that he's going to
catch more charges in possible more
jurisdictions right
but this is the cognitive dissidence
that they have
I mean look at this from Bridget Gabriel
have you guys ever seen this this
account on Twitter this is [__]
insanity
Bridget Gabriel post this picture of
trump now she says the left is terrified
of masculinity
it's a big part of why they hate Trump
okay the web is not terrified of
masculinity you bonehead the left knows
what masculinity is the right thinks
toxic masculinity is the only type of
masculinity
there is a way to have manhood and be
manly without having to be inherently
toxic like Tucker Carlson Donald Trump
Andrew Tate Russell Brand Elon Musk the
list goes on and on and on with not only
these accused rapists but these
convicted rapists and Donald Trump
in the Eugene t e Gene Carroll trial
but here's the picture she posted of
Donald Trump
I'm not [__] you now again this is
all [__] fake it's AI but she posts
this
has proved positive of Donald Trump's
masculinity not only has this never this
[__] never ever ever ever
dressed like this he's never had a
reason to dress like this and it is
actually offensive to people who go out
and work their asses off every [__]
day
who put on this uniform and do this work
that it that the AI is showing him to do
here pretending that he does here right
it is [__] offensive
it's laughable it's hilarious that that
they would fall for this [__] that
somehow Donald Trump would put any of
this on
and do this job no [__] way
no [__] way this guy wouldn't lift a
[__] finger like the American middle
class has done and built this country
sometimes built this country
and Donald Trump not [__] paid them
it's [__] ridiculous but here's what
I say keep this up you [__] [__]
because these [__] delusion will be
Donald Trump's ultimate demise because
when someone in the country sees this
and knows the real truth about Donald
Trump isn't [__] deluded like the
lady we just saw isn't part of the cult
isn't a [__] sheep and I'm not
talking about Republicans I'm talking
about anyone out there who really
doesn't pay attention to politics
but sees this picture
and knows its AI knows it's fake and not
only knows that it's [__] an AI image
that there is no [__] way in hell on
any Planet other than artificially
made up that Donald Trump would be
anywhere near a situation where he would
have a job like this get the [__] out of
here with these lies
but keep going
keep going this is making it worse for
Trump
it's making it worse for him
folks he is not popular do not listen to
the [__] media tell you a bunch of
[__] that him and Biden are neck and
neck it is not the truth
go look at the evidence that you have
before you
go look at the evidence of the 2022
midterms of the 2020 election some of
the special elections leading up to this
next election
go look at the evidence those are the
polls you should be listening to those
are the polls that you should be
referring to there was supposed to be a
huge Red Wave remember
and really without New York doing what
they did with their districts Kevin
McCarthy would not even had a chance to
be the Speaker of the House
if if we would have done our job as a
pro-democracy coalition and engage just
a little further just pushed it a little
harder
Lauren bober wouldn't be a cop she would
be the former congresswoman juicing the
beetle in a Denver theater
that's what the headline would be former
former congresswoman
Lauren Berber juices the beetle of a
Democrat bar owner who has drag shows at
that bar that would be the headline
if we would just a little more just a
little more push
but they can't help but help us by
putting out images like this
are you serious
come on now
we know it's fake but not only is fake
as it's laughable
and it only hurts their narrative here
because the truth is glaring
that he's nowhere near
has the backbone and the masculinity
and the tenacity
and and the patriotism of the middle
class in this country of working people
actual working people who would put that
[__] hard hat on
who would put those blue jeans and
gloves on it do that dirty work to build
America to advance the American economy
the workers
Jesus Christ the UAW
told him to [__] off
we are fighting against people like you
the billionaires
the one percent the people trying to
[__] keep their foot on our goddamn
heads and drown Us in this economy while
they get richer and richer
and they can't stop they can't stop
saying it even Tim Scott listen to this
this here's Tim Scott in Iowa I don't
know why he's still running for oh
that's right he's trying to raise money
so DeSantis can't raise it that's what
it is oh okay he's Tim Scott I don't
want to give you a secret here Tim Scott
is running to suck up big money donors
money for Trump
so that DeSantis doesn't get it and
Pence doesn't get it that's that's what
he's there for
is to be a backstop for the big money
right he's raised a [__] ton of it this
guy
this guy's Senator Tim Scott the closet
excuse me the senator from South
Carolina I didn't mean closet I meant
South closet and South Carolina
South Carolina I don't know hey that and
actually you know what that's got a hell
of a ring to it
it's kind of over and good
South closelina
I mean the Senators there seem to love
you know and just just saying
listen to what Tim Scott says here
listen to how he shits
listen to how this [__] shits
all over average Americans
just shits on them
and he loves billionaires oh he loves
the jab creators
hey [__]
the consumer is the job Creator it's the
consumer who is the job creator
that's who is the job Creator when we
buy when we spend our money when we in
the capitalist system of democracy
choose to vote with our dollars
that's the job Creator okay that's how
that works we just need to stop making
making sure we give all the [__] GDP
to the billionaires instead of the
workers but Tim Scott wants to make sure
the billionaires get all the GDP listen
to this Ronald Reagan gave us a great
example when federal employees said it
was strike
respect you're fired
civil concept to me to the city that we
can use that once again absolutely
Ronald Reagan if you strike you're fired
and this is all coming coming at a time
when workers in this country are not
getting paid the appropriate amount of
GDP
they are not receiving the amount of GDP
that is fair
and I know everyone wants to talk about
wages and stuff which everyone should be
able to earn a decent [__] wage
you should be able to earn a decent
[__] wage in this country but the
other thing you should do is
collectively bargain so that the workers
in this country get a the fair share
portion of the gross domestic product
that one percent should not get
99.999999 of our gross domestic product
we are the ones who do the work we are
the ones who consume [__] you oh you
want to be rich cool you can be rich
you're just gonna have to pay a shitload
of taxes can you believe we live in a
[__] country where this [__]
scumbag Tim Scott is talking this kind
of trash on middle class and working
Americans
and propping up Millionaires and
billionaires
who receive a [__] tax break to buy a
yacht
do you know that aren't tax code allows
for rich people to buy yachts and buy
private airplanes and get a tax break
not the other way it should be way the
other way around if you want to buy a
private airplane in this country or a
private yacht in this country over a
certain size or a certain amount we
should tax you 90 percent of whatever
the [__] that yacht or that plane cost
that's what we should be doing
you do not need a private yacht you do
not need a private blame if you want one
more power to you
more power to you if you want a private
yacht that cost 600 million dollars oh
you want a private jet that costs 500
million dollars fine great we're going
to tax the [__] out of you then
for that luxury you [__] idiot
and if you have enough money if you have
enough money that you can blow on a 500
million dollars 600 800 million dollars
a billion dollars on a yacht then you
sure as hell have the money to blow on
the tanks
if that's what you want to have fine
cool we can do that that sounds good to
me but it is the opposite the truth is
the [__] opposite
they get a tax break
folks
Trump did that [__]
you know the thing to do Trump trump cut
taxes truck you know what Trump did oh
he did great for the economy oh it's so
great when you talk to these mongolites
you're like what do you like about what
Trump uh he cut taxes
he cut taxes on [__] private jets and
Yachts you [__] boneheads
when's the last time when's the last
time your cousin Dwayne
that lives on three acres
in a trailer had the opportunity to get
a tax break on a yacht huh when's the
last time Dwayne win pointed out to me
Billy Bob Bob Jeff pointed out to me
when the last time you had the
opportunity to get a tax break of a
private plane
[__] out of here with this nonsense that
Trump the best thing he did was cut
taxes yeah the best thing he did was cut
taxes for the rich
that's why the rich are excited that's
why Republicans are excited because
their donors got all the [__] tax
breaks and they're gonna stuff their
pockets to go get them more
and Tim Scott thinks if you strike and
you won't allow a company to make profit
off the exploitation of your labor well
then we'll fire you
try it [__] do it do it do it do it
solidarity [__] yeah fire our
ass do it I dare you do it
I'm telling you there is a there is a
there is a headwind in this country of
workers rights to their labor and to
negotiate their labor and to get paid
what they should be paid for their
[__] labor
so Tim Scott can [__] all the way off
with him and his Rich [__] donors
because that's the key here about 10
Scott that I told you in the beginning
the reason why Tim Scott is in the
[__] race in to begin with
is to suck up
all the money from the rich [__]
donors to Rhonda santis doesn't get it
so Donald Trump can be the nominee
period
and what does he have to do when he gets
that rich money donors he has to go
[__] capitulate to them
can't be out here saying all workers
need rights workers need decent wages
because those big money donors would
pull their money in a hurry
Tim Scott has no principle he has no
Foundation he doesn't believe in
democracy he doesn't like our country he
he does he hates
he hates this country hates it
and he's willing to sell his entire
[__] soul out and sell his
constituents and the rest of the
American people out for a few [__]
dollars
so that he can get a tax break on a
yacht that he might buy one day and a
private airplane that he might buy one
day the [__] out of here with this
nonsense and get the [__] out of here
with Tim Scott
Uncle Uncle Scott [__] Uncle Tom get
a wife get a life go go get a [__]
life like you pretend to have a
girlfriend
foreign
should we go back to some of these let's
see if we got some Jim Jordan Clips I
really want to see we got we got about
we got about 10 minutes left let's see
if I can find some good Jim Jordan clips
I want a really good one where he just
gets his ass stomped here
anyone got a really good one
um now let's see oh here here we go
here's uh apparently swalwell
I called out
um
that's that's not a very that's not a
good clip that I want apparently there
is a clip out there where Eric swallow
here it is Eric swallow just owned Maga
Republican uh Jim Jordan aka Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan
at the house Committee hearing with
mayor Garland um so and I as I suspected
Eric swallow would dunk Jim Jordan in
the trash and let's let's take a look at
this clip here to see how it all how it
all came together the chair recognizes
the uh the gentleman from California
Mr attorney general my colleague just
said that you should be held in contempt
of congress and that is quite Rich
because the guy who's leaving the
hearing room right now Mr Jordan is
about 500 days into evading his team
about 500 days so if we're going to talk
about intent of Congress let's get real
I mean are you serious that Jim Jordan
a witness to one of the greatest crimes
ever committed in America a crime where
more prosecutions have occurred than any
crime committed in America refuses to
help his country and we're going to get
lectured
about subpoena compliance and contempt
of congress Jim Jordan won't even honor
a lawful subpoena
are you kidding me are you kidding me
there's no credibility on that side
Mr attorney general you are serious they
are not
you are decent they are not
you are fair
they are not so I welcome you to the law
firm of insurrection LLP where they work
every single day on behalf of one client
Donald Trump and they do that at the
expense of millions of Americans who
need the government to stay open who
want their kids safe in their schools
and would like to see Ukraine stay in
the fight so that we don't help Russia
that's the expense that this nonsense
this clown show I'd call it a clown show
except they actually have real
responsibilities that affect Real
Americans
it's the difference between one side
that believes in governing and one side
that believes in ruling
you've tried to comply with this
Committee in fact last week one of your
special agents came here for an
interview brought his lawyer
and was told that he couldn't have his
lawyer present Mr Jordan who tells all
of us he knows so much about the
Constitution wouldn't afford one of your
employees one of the basic
constitutional rights to have a lawyer
president in fact they threatened to
call the Capitol Police and arrest a
lawyer
that was brought are you familiar with
that
standoff that occurred last week Mr
attorney general uh generally yes well
your office also sent a letter detailing
it that you were willing to comply but
you'd like him to have a lawyer and I'd
like to submit that to the record with
unanimous consent not objection who
appointed Mr Weiss
well Mr Trump was the last person who
appointed Mr Weiss to the position of
U.S attorney I appointed him to the
position of special counsel last month
who initially appointed John Durham
Mr Durham was I believe also appointed
by President Trump
um and uh Mr Bauer appointed him a
special counsel and again these guys are
so upset that Donald Trump's appointed
prosecutors aren't doing enough of the
corruption that Donald Trump wants him
to do so either they are just following
the law or they're not
as corrupt and they're not willing to go
as far as they think that Donald Trump
deserves that's what they're asking to
happen here
also doesn't it seem that they want it
both ways when it comes to the special
counsel a lot of questions
suggested that the special counsel
should be independent but when they
didn't like the direction of the special
counsel you were asked why you didn't
interfere more or involve yourself more
or investigate more did you get that
sense that
you're kind of stuck here
when I make an appointment somebody be a
special counsel or prosecutor
the appointment is without respect to
what the outcomes of the case uh will be
your office has made a number of reforms
to 702 targeting foreign Nationals but
those reforms have not been put into law
702 is also one of the best weapons we
have to go after fentanyl can you tell
us if you would support putting some of
those reforms into law so we don't have
to live Administration to Administration
to see if they're going to be following
I I would uh section 702 provides us
with the greatest amount at least uh
justice department every morning the
greatest amount of intelligence that we
receive about dangerous threats to the
United States from foreign Nationals
from foreign Nationals I yeah it doesn't
detail domestic terrorists like
Republicans that's a whole nother report
um um uh quite aware and sensitive to
civil liberties concerns uh with respect
to the queries
um and for that reason I put into place
and extend I extended some of those that
Mr Barr had begun at the end of his term
and I put further ones in place those
have led to a dramatic uh reduction in
the number of queries and a dramatic
reduction uh in the number of a
non-compliant queries I believe those
are appropriate reforms
um and I would be in favor of codifying
them yes thank you Mr attorney general
and thank you for coming and doing
something that the chairman is unwilling
to do testify to Congress
Eric's small little after my heart
yes big Steph man yeah and I did show
Steve Cohen going after gas but this
this one here of Eric swallow going
after Jim Jordan because Jim Jordan
apparently is very upset and wants to
hold Merrick Garland contempt to
Congress even though he isn't contempt
for comics for more than 500 Days on a
subpoena as Eric swallow puts it based
on it because they want to get to the
bottom and the truth of the biggest
crime that has ever taken place in
American history more people have been
prosecuted convicted and put in prison
because of January 6th than any other
scheme in this country or any other coup
oh boy oh boy
I'm sure there's going to be more Clips
coming from this hearing we will play
him tomorrow I was waiting for the
swallow clip I told you that I knew
there was going to be a swallow clip
when I started listening I knew that
because he was coming on as soon as I
came on the air I think I was backwards
though I was I was paused so now I want
to give you some news here
um also we're going to take a few
minutes because we're not we're not
shooting to Gabe uh what was that live
today now we are we are
with the library of democracy's YouTube
channel here's the news we are at 949 we
were just
51 subscribers away from getting the
library of democracy's YouTube channel
to a thousand which is the goal so
please uh I'm gonna put it in the chat
again if you have not subbed to the
library of democracy's YouTube channel
You're Gonna Wanna Do it now I'm putting
it in the chat right now so take that
link go to the library of democracy or
you can go to the Tony michaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com the link is
there
uh at the at the top here let me let me
show you here uh on here you go if you
go to the Tony michaels.com hit
subscribe at the top of the
tonymichaels.com and then pan down the
library of democracy is right here you
can find that link there or you can just
go to YouTube and search the library of
democracy you will be able to find it
very easy but again go follow the
library of democracy your for all the
comparisons of project 2025 there's
going to be videos that are coming out
within the next week that are going to
show you how to engage in your democracy
quick and easy ways so you're going to
want to go to the library democracy
while I'm on the Tony Michaels podcast D
Tony michaels.com again subscribe at the
top I'll send you notifications for each
day for each Show's link on YouTube
um also you can buy me a shot it's
Wednesday it's karaoke day if you want
to send me a chat I'll put it up on the
screen you just go to the venmo Super
Chat so thanks to everyone who has
bought shots of venmo Super Chat and if
you want to get in on patreon speaking
of karaoke we're new karaoke next month
you'll have the opportunity to sign up
to appear with me on screen while I do
Comic Cons and karaoke I appreciate all
the support that you guys give again I
could not keep this microphone on
without you you are the reason why this
microphone is on whether you give
monetary support or you're here every
day listening engaging with the audience
engaging with the [__] fam over on
the Discord engaging with the [__]
fam I appreciate every single way that
you support this show and that's why
we'll be back tomorrow at the same time
same place Surf's Up [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fish repeat after me
[__] them
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn headass Beacon
some of y'all know I do every week a
podcast I do every week a podcast I do a
podcast every week I do a podcast three
days a week I do a podcast I do a
podcast I do a podcast last year I
launched a podcast two years ago I
launched a podcast three years ago I
launched a podcast I do a podcast my
last podcast today's podcast on the
podcast podcast or my podcast back to
katanji Brown Jackson's confirmation
hearing you know a couple of years ago I
was doing my weekly podcast my podcast
my podcast my podcast my podcast my
podcast my podcast my podcast podcast
podcast
[Music]
if you're a grifter you got a grift
podcast
some of y'all know I do have